Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great thing. for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the story has reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect
嗨，我是Max，我在西约克郡的学习障碍服务中心担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是考取临床心理学博士学位。怀着这个最终目标，我想看看市面上有什么书能对此有所帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家集体》，并认为这对我的旅程大有裨益。我发现玛丽安的书非常有启发性，见解深刻。我特别喜欢书中的故事，它让我确信你不需要在学术上做到完美
to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, nor so those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. What if the person you've stopped trusting is yourself? Not because you're weak, not because you're incapable, but because somewhere along the way, someone or something taught you that your instincts couldn't be trusted. Maybe it was burnout, maybe it was an unhealthy relationship. Maybe years of criticism drowned out your own voice. Today, I want to explore what it really means to begin to trust yourself as a lot.
才能成为一名心理学家，只要你具备良好的社交技能，比如同情心和共情能力，你就能达到目标。我强烈向所有有志于成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，也推荐给那些想更多了解临床心理学世界的人，它让我渴望有一天能在这个领域工作。如果那个你不再信任的人是你自己，那该怎么办？不是因为你软弱，不是因为你无能，而是因为在人生的某个阶段，某人或某事让你觉得自己的直觉不可信。也许是因为职业倦怠，也许是因为一段不健康的关系。也许是多年的批评淹没了你自己的声音。今天，我想探讨一下开始信任自己到底意味着什么。
I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, welcome to Inner Work. This week in the main episode, Psychology Actually, I'm chatting with Dr. Ellie all about her time on the traitors and what trust is. But I thought we'd take a little look in Inner Work about what trusting yourself looks like, which can be a very different ballgame than trusting or distrusting others, mainly because we are always with ourselves and that can make life quite tricky. One of my colleagues and psychologist trainers once said, I think there's often a very good and important reason why this shows up for you, why this shows up for us. And that is certainly the case when it comes to
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，欢迎来到《内在工作》。本周的主集《心理学其实》中，我将与艾莉博士畅谈她参加《叛徒》节目的经历以及什么是信任。但我认为我们应该在《内在工作》中深入探讨一下信任自己是什么样子的，这与信任或不信任他人完全是两码事，主要是因为我们时刻与自己相处，这会让生活变得相当棘手。我的一位同事兼心理学培训师曾经说过，我认为这种感觉之所以出现，之所以在我们身上出现，往往有一个非常好且重要的原因。当涉及到
feeling like you can't trust your own judgment. So let's take a look. So often when I'm working with adults who might report to me that they've had, you know, anxiety or depression showing up for them at different periods of their life, on and off, on and off, and they don't really know why. They'll be like, well, you know, I've had a pretty good upbringing. My parents are all right. You know, came from a happy home. So, I don't know, it's just me, isn't it? Like, I'm the problem, it's me. And then over time, as we begin to take a little bit of a look about actually what their early experiences were like, we can often begin to piece together that actually maybe things in their development, their early years, their first 18 years, were not as calm, we're not as
感觉自己无法相信自己的判断时，情况确实如此。让我们来看看。当我与那些报告说在人生不同阶段断断续续出现焦虑或抑郁，却不知道原因的成年人工作时，他们经常会说，嗯，你知道，我的成长环境还不错。我的父母都很好。你知道，我来自一个幸福的家庭。所以，我不知道，这只是我自己的问题，对吧？我是那个问题所在，是我。然后随着时间的推移，当我们开始稍微审视一下他们早年的经历时，我们往往能拼凑出，实际上，也许他们在成长过程中的某些事情，他们早年，最初的18年，并不像
consistent, we're not as predictable, and we're not as safe as they deserved for them to be. Not because they're a queen, not because they're a king, not because they're a princess, but because all of us, you know, regardless of who we are, when we're born, when we grow, when we develop, we deserve to have a safe, good enough childhood, where we are loved, where we are protected, where we are fed, where we are clothed, where there's consistency, where there's boundaries. And really, that might sound like very simple things that humans need, but that is really the bare bones about what helps us to thrive. So when we look back on people's lives sometimes and they're like, well,
他们应得的那样平静、稳定、可预测和安全。这并不是因为他们是女王、国王或公主，而是因为我们所有人，无论我们是谁，当我们出生、成长和发展时，我们都理应拥有一个安全、足够好的童年，在那里我们被爱、被保护、有饭吃、有衣穿、有稳定性、有界限。这听起来可能只是人类所需的基本需求，但这确实是帮助我们茁壮成长的基础。所以，当我们回顾人们的生活时，有时他们会说，嗯，
you know, my parents were in a domestically violent relationship. One of my parents was low in mood, depressed and was thinking about suicide at one stage. You know, maybe someone in the house or went to prison or, you know, maybe we were hit as children and I was really scared for my own safety or the safety of my siblings. or maybe just do you know that sense that your family didn't feel the same as other people's families. We begin to piece together a little bit of a presentation which might then explain why trusting ourselves and trusting other people might feel problematic. Because if we've always been told bad things about ourselves or that we haven't been raised
你知道，我的父母处于一段充满家庭暴力的关系中。我的一位家长情绪低落、抑郁，甚至一度想过自杀。你知道，也许家里有人入狱，或者，你知道，也许我们小时候被打过，我真的很担心自己或兄弟姐妹的安全。或者仅仅是那种感觉，你的家庭感觉和其他人的家庭不一样。我们开始拼凑出一点点情况，这或许能解释为什么信任自己和信任他人会感觉有问题。因为如果我们总是被告知关于自己的坏事，或者我们没有被以一种
in a way that makes us think we can achieve and we can produce an outcome that is something we're striving for and that it's okay for us to strive for things, then we're very quickly going to begin to undermine our own hopes, our own dreams. I really like the book by Simon Squibb called What's Your Dream? Because it really can get us to think, right, if I took all of the expectations, all of the self-limitations off myself and just allowed myself to think, what would genuinely light me up, you know? How can I do? trust myself to back myself to get me where I would want to be if I took away all of that external noise or maybe sometimes even that internal noise. And I love it. His philosophy where
让我们认为自己可以成功、可以实现我们所追求的目标，并且追求这些目标是没问题的方式抚养长大，那么我们很快就会开始破坏自己的希望和梦想。我真的很喜欢西蒙·斯奎布写的《你的梦想是什么？》这本书。因为它真的能让我们思考，对，如果我卸下所有的期望和自我限制，只允许自己思考，什么才是真正能点亮我的东西，你知道吗？如果我排除了所有外部噪音，甚至有时是内部噪音，我该如何信任自己，支持自己去往我想去的地方？我喜欢他的哲学，即
he's like, you know, I'm going to give you this money to get you started to get you over this first hurdle, you know, because then, you know, who are we kidding? If we're not getting our dreams, if we're not backing ourselves because we've been saying this reason why I can't do it and then that reason is taken away, then I think, you know, we do then have to do the inner work. We have to be curious to think about why we are getting in our own way. And it might be an element of self-preservation, which is okay, you know, because doing new things does feel a bit scary, does feel a bit risky. But I think it is just holding it gently with curiosity and having a look at it and thinking,
他说，你知道，我要给你这笔钱让你开始，帮你跨过第一个障碍，你知道，因为然后，你知道，我们在骗谁呢？如果我们没有实现梦想，如果我们没有支持自己，因为我们一直在说我做不到的理由，而当那个理由被消除后，那么我想，你知道，我们确实必须进行内在工作。我们必须保持好奇心，思考为什么我们在阻碍自己。这可能是一种自我保护，这没关系，你知道，因为做新事物确实感觉有点可怕，确实感觉有点冒险。但我认为这只是需要带着好奇心温柔地对待它，审视它并思考，
What is that about? Is that genuinely true? Or is this a decision that I'm making based on old information or, you know, information that I'm imagining might come to pass in the future? So just be watchful. If you're getting in your own way or if it feels like, you know, other people will say things, just take a look, see what you think. I would love to know what you do think. What is this bringing up for you? What is your dream? Are you able to trust yourself with it so that you can achieve? I would love to know. Thank you so much for being here. The next episode of Inner Work is at 8pm on Wednesday. And if you've enjoyed this episode, I think you'll really like this one on screen, which is about stopping, waiting to be chosen and choosing yourself, controlling your own destiny.
这是怎么回事？这是真的吗？还是我基于旧信息，或者你知道，我想象未来可能会发生的信息所做出的决定？所以要保持警惕。如果你在阻碍自己，或者如果感觉，你知道，别人会说些什么，那就看看，看看你怎么想。我很想知道你的想法。这给你带来了什么？你的梦想是什么？你能信任自己去实现它吗？我很想知道。非常感谢你的收听。下一期《内在工作》将于周三晚上8点播出。如果你喜欢这一集，我想你会喜欢屏幕上的这一集，它是关于停止等待被选择，转而选择自己，掌控自己的命运。
Thanks for being part of my world. I'll see you soon. Take care. I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an end goal,
感谢你成为我世界的一部分。很快再见。保重。我是乔，我在兰开夏郡的CAM服务中心担任助理从业者。我购买并阅读了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家集体》，以陪伴我完成临床心理学培训申请。事实证明，它确实是一个很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它提供了沉浸在他人故事中的机会。它及时提醒我不要太纠结于最终目标，
and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way, because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside, as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though,
并要重视和享受我们一路走来所履行的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都很重要。它还让我确信，进入临床心理学有多种多样的途径，这对我来说很重要，因为我走过弯路，并不是典型的职业路线。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过要做好准备，暂时搁置晚上的任务，
because once you've started reading, it's tough to put it down. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为一旦你开始阅读，就很难放下。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。